[Music]  and where have you come from i've come  from cheshire  i've driven from treasure so it took me  eight hours and normally my staying  power is about two  so why was it important to continue to  be closer  i wanted to be closer i've been here  i've been to the balmoral area about 40  years ago when i was a soldier  but i just wanted to be here today to  waver off  so it's  almost like a family member  it's an emotional day now here for us in  the village it's our chance to say  goodbye  i've never come along to anything like  this before but just really felt that i  wanted it was it was important  it was it was quite overwhelming to be  honest i'm very very proud to be here  [Music]  so  [Applause]  [Music]  quack uh